bonjour et bienvenue dans ce cas les
missions qui parle de livres qui parlent
de sciences humaines pour ce huitième
épisode on va s'attaquer à un domaine où
on n'a pas parlé précédemment à savoir
la psychologie cognitive
donc en fait la psychologie cognitive
c'est toutes les fonctions
psychologiques telles que la mémoire le
raisonnement ou la perception toutes les
fonctions qui vont conditionner notre
appréhension au monde
l'auteur dont on va parler aujourd'hui à
savoir james risen c'est un expert du
domaine et sa connaissance du cerveau
humain
il va l'utiliser pour une thématique
principale à savoir la gestion des
risques la théorie et les modèles de
jeans brisa non sans aucun doute
contribué à sauver un nombre
incalculable de vies et à mieux
comprendre en quoi le cerveau était à la
fois une machine formidable et une
machine capable d'un nombre incalculable
d'erreurs on va donc essayer de
s'intéresser à cette théorie est assez
moderne et ça commence maintenant
obama
james risen est un professeur de
psychologie de l'université de
manchester
il est spécialisé dans ce que l'on
appelle la gestion des facteurs humains
c'est-à-dire en fait l'étude de la
contribution humaine qui est impliqué
dans un événement
cette étude elle est surtout envisagé
afin de sécuriser et de faciliter
certaines tâches humaine ce domaine
d'étude il a principalement été impulsée
par et pour le domaine de l'aviation
dans un avion la gestion des facteurs
humains permet de comprendre les
raisonnements du pilote qui est six
pieds au sein du cockpit car on peut
essayer de sécuriser la machine tant
qu'on veut si on prend pas en compte les
potentiels réaction erreur certitude
limites de l'humain qui pilote la
machine on court nécessairement à
l'accident cette étude ne se limite pas
aux interactions avec la machine aussi
aux échanges avec par exemple le pilote
et le copilote tout le pilote avec la
tour de contrôle
bien évidemment ce domaine ne se limite
pas aux avions et s'étend de nombreuses
autres activités telles que le monde
hospitalier ou bien l'ingénierie
nucléaire par exemple vous l'aurez
compris la gestion des facteurs humains
elle est surtout orientée vers des
domaines où on avait honte pas trop
droit à l'erreur comme quand on fait
atterrir 747 quand on manipule du
plutonium ou alors quand on fait une
chirurgie à coeur ouvert
james êtes un grand expert de ce domaine
de la gestion des facteurs humains et à
ce titre il l'a théorisé plusieurs types
de défaillance humaine
d'un côté les défaillances active c'est
à dire qu'ils sont liés directement à un
acteur en prise directe avec le problème
qui survient par exemple au bloc
opératoire
c'est un soignant qui va sortir deux
ampoules différentes et qui va préparer
la mauvaise injection oui françoise
c'est bien la norad ray whitney je
n'avais jamais vu de jaune fluo du coup
je m'inquiétais non mais je m'inquiète
plus jeunes inquiète plus bien
évidemment on imagine bien que ces
défaillances actives elles peuvent être
dû à un nombre incalculable de facteurs
ça peut être les conditions de travail
la fatigue ou le nombre de tâches à
effectuer en même temps sur un moment
donné d'un autre côté on a les erreurs
qui sont dus au système dans lequel le
problème survient c'est ce qu'on appelle
les erreurs l'attend si on reprend par
exemple l'erreur d'injection au bloc
opératoire une erreur l'attend ce serait
par exemple que deux ampoules qui font
quelque chose de radicalement différent
avec des dosages radicalement différents
soient marqués de la même façon avec un
packaging qui est relativement similaire
ou qu'elles soient stockées juste à côté
oui françoise je reviens vers toi elle
était bien
dans le tiroir de droite le titre n'ont
pas le tiroir de droite non le tiroir de
droite
ce sont donc des problématiques
organisationnelles qui encourage
directement la subvenu d'une erreur dans
le cadre de l'activité
enfin on a une dernière défaillance qui
est donc là défaillances d'ordre
technique c'est-à-dire un problème qui
survient à cause directement d'une
machine ou d'un objet qui est engagée
qui est compris dans l'activité dans le
bloc opératoire toujours si la seringue
casse ou si le respirateur tombe en
panne on va parler de défaillances
d'ordre technique ou il françoise je
sais que l'écran dit que tout va bien
mais bon je me dis les lèvres bleues bon
peut-être un indice donc voilà pour les
trois types de défaillance on va essayer
de les reprendre toutes les trois dans
le monde de l'aviation cette fois-ci
histoire de bien les intégrer
donc la situation est la suivante un
pilote demande son altitude aux
contrôleurs au sol et l'information
qu'on lui transmet n'est pas conforme
avec l'altitude qui constate dans son
cockpit si l'altitude est affichée
clairement la vue du pilote et que
l'altitude affichée est la bonne alors
l'erreur dans la communication est
plutôt lié à une défaillance du pilote
celui ci a mal lu ou a mal compris
l'information transmise on parle de
défaillance active
si l'altitude est par exemple très peu
lisible ou très proches d'une
information similaire alors l'erreur
dans la lecture du pilote est
potentiellement liés à l'organisation du
cockpit c'est à dire à son ergonomie
l'erreur est alors l'attend si
l'altitude affichée est clairement
lisible mais que celle ci est erronée
alors on assiste à une erreur dans votre
technique mais en fait lors de l'arrivée
d'un événement grave comme le crash d'un
avion ou alors la mort d'un patient dans
une salle d'opération
l'erreur si erreur il ya n'est jamais
attribuable à un seul facteur
c'est donc souvent une association de
défaillances techniques humaines et
organisationnelles qui vont générer
l'accident james risen des élites
laïques dit deux choses 2 1
il dit que l'erreur est inséparable de
l'intelligence humaine donc l'humain
doit être placé au coeur du système de
lutte contre l'erreur deuxièmement il
dit que ce face à ces multiples facteurs
d'erreurs il faut pas mettre en place un
système de défense contre l'erreur mais
plutôt une suite de remparts qui vont
permettre de prévenir l'accident
c'est ce que l'on appelle les plaques de
reason le fromage le réseau
bon vous comprenez directement est la
référence aux produits laitiers vu le
schéma moi je trouve personnellement que
l'image du fromage a pas grand chose la
foule là dedans mais bon si ça vous
permet de mieux visualiser
éventuellement vous pouvez voir une
tranche des montagnes pour nous
comprendre ce système on va reprendre un
exemple du monde hospitalier et on va
prendre une erreur qui est
malheureusement est arrivé dans plein de
blocs opératoires différents à savoir le
fait que le mauvais côté d'un patient
soit opérée en l'occurrence on va
prendre l'exemple de la mauvaise jambe
qui est opéré par le chirurgien
bon voilà la marque pas une prothèse
tout neuf je suis assez fier de moi et
je me suis trompé de jambes je me suis
trompé de jambes
oui alors d'accord oui il avait selon
comment on regarde ça fait que cela
fausse un peu le oui bon oui mais france
françoise woets mais n'essayez pas de
partir prendre revenez ici française
oui vous m'avez donné le dossier un
petit peu je me rappelle de façon à
l'envers à l'endroit de façon un petit
peu ambigu bon j'aime pas dénoncer mais
donc face à ce risque
imaginons la mise en place d'une plaque
de reason on va mettre en place la règle
que maintenant avant d'arriver en salle
d'opération
l'infirmier qui amène le patient salle
va lui demander de confirmer qu'elle est
la jambe qui doit être opéré donc on
peut supposer que cette plaque va la
plupart du temps permettent de bien
déterminer quelle jambe est malade et
aussi de ne pas se tromper lorsqu'il
s'agira de l'ouvrir cependant cette
plaque comme toutes les mesures de
sécurité contient des faiblesses c'est à
dire d'être où le patient pu être par
exemple confus dément ou simplement
stressé et se tromper de jambes
lorsqu'il indique ammar firme la seule
mais peut se tromper en transmettre
l'information aux géorgiens le
chirurgien peut mal comprendre
l'information
il peut s'agir de la bonne jambe mais du
mauvais patients etc etc
on voit bien qu'une seule et unique
mesure n'est pas capable de prémunir de
l'accident la logique de reason du coup
c'est de proposer une superposition de
plaques pour se prémunir un maximum
contre l'arrivée d'un événement
indésirable tout en gardant à l'esprit
que toutes ces plaques individuellement
contiennent des failles
bon ok mais là martin c'est pas la bonne
jambe après moi je dis il faut rien
regretter je vous ai mis
la rotule allemande c'était de la
qualité ces deux-là lui vous pouvez y
aller ça ne bougera jamais vous
corporellement vous serez partie la
rotule sera encore là précisons ici
qu'on peut voir ces plaques de deux
façons ces plaques peuvent être vues
soit comme une succession de mesures
donc les vérifications avant l'opération
la présence du dossier le marquage on
peut voir aussi ses plaques comme la
succession des domaines qui contribuent
à la sécurité
ça peut être le design la culture de la
sécurité
l'expertisé en sécurité des acteurs ou
les différentes procédures qui sont
mises en place
cette vision des plaques de reason
dépend de l'utilisation qu'on veut en
faire et du domaine dans lequel celui-ci
sera employé pour cette opération à la
jambe par exemple on va donc demander au
patient son identité et la jambe
concernées avant de partir de la chambre
en arrivant devant le bloc opératoire et
encore une fois lorsqu'il est entré dans
la salle d'opération on va confronter
ces informations au dossier qui est
disponible auprès du patient mais qui
est également disponible
informatiquement auprès de l'équipe
opératoire ces exemples ne sont qu'une
petite partie de toutes les précautions
à prendre avant le début d'un acte
chirurgical et comme dans l'aviation il
va y avoir une check list
et si tous les éléments toutes les
précautions ne sont pas rencontrés alors
l'opération ne peut débuter
aussi pour que l'événement indésirable
arrive il faudrait que toutes les
failles du système
sa ligne et laisse l'accident arrivé
toujours dans le cas d'une opération qui
se passerait du mauvais côté mais il
faudrait par exemple que le patient se
trompent plusieurs fois en montrant la
jambe à opérer que le dossier montrent
la mauvaise information que personnes
vérifient ce qui est dit entre le
patient et le dossier bref dans un avion
comme dans une centrale nucléaire ou
dans un bloc opératoire cela garantit
jamais une sécurité à 100% mais ça
permet de réduire drastiquement tous les
risques qui sont liées aux activités
bon alors oui certes c'était pas de nos
malades après vu la rotule que j'ai
sorti à mon avis on a rien à regretter
là avec la rotule de compet que je vous
ai mis dans deux ans ces jeux olympiques
ces 110 m haies et ses médailles d'or
évidemment ces plaques et donc ces
mesures ces procédures
elles ne viennent pas de nulle part et
elle émane de trois types de gestion
différente de la sécurité une gestion
réactive proactive et prédictive une
gestion réactive comme son nom l'indiqué
c'est avoir une réaction face
accident qui s'est déroulé on va avoir
recours à ce qu'on appelle les rex ou
retours d'expériences ainsi que ce qu'on
appelle les revues de mortalité
morbidité
on va tenter de déterminer quels ont été
les mécanismes de l'erreur en marche
parce qu'un accident est arrivé pour en
déduire des solutions pour que ça
n'arrive plus on a également ce qu'on
appelle une gestion proactive c'est à
dire une observation et des comptes
rendus qui sont faits sur l'activité
le but est de réaliser une sorte de
cartes schémas de l'activité pour
déterminer où les erreurs sont
susceptibles d'arriver avant qu'elle
n'arrive
enfin on a ce qu'on appelle à une
gestion prédictive de l'événement qui
est là plutôt une surveillance sont sous
marin de l'activité afin de pouvoir
identifier des dysfonctionnements qui
peuvent amener à les accidents
évidemment pour aboutir à une gestion
des risques efficace
on assiste souvent à une association des
trois types de gestion pour pouvoir
avoir une vision sur tous les angles et
avoir la meilleure prévention possible
des accidents qui pourraient arriver
donc james risen ça n'a pas été le
premier à s'intéresser à ces questions
là mais c'est un acteur hypra important
de cette thématique de la gestion des
facteurs humains donc encore une fois
ces théories et ses modèles ont
influencé et influencent encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup la façon dont on
essaye de prévenir les accidents dans
les milieux à risques voilà pour cette
émission comme d'habitude je vous laisse
pas seul dans la nuit et je vous
conseille de contenu pour pouvoir
poursuivi cette thématique vous
intéresse donc d'abord je vous encourage
à regarder des gens qui se pète la
trompe
en plus d'être relativement drôle c'est
aussi un bon moyen d'exercer cette
théorie comme un devoir à savoir est ce
que c'est une erreur qui est active
l'attend technique
est-ce que ça rapide prévu commence à
rappeler de prévu voilà ça m'arrive de
le faire quand je conduis
jugez pas la seconde vidéo que je vous
invite à regarder c'est une vidéo de
james risen lui même qui explique son
modèle et ses divers ramifications règne
pour le moment où il est en train de
tenir d'autres tranches de fromage pour
expliquer sa théorie ça vaut donc voilà
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à la partager
vous pouvez et surtout vous le souhaitez
n'hésitez pas également à vous abonner
afin de pouvoir être tenu au courant des
prochaines vidéos qui vont sortir
en attendant je vous souhaite une
superbe journée soirée une nuit tout ce
que vous voulez et on se dit ah la
prochaine salut on appris du rab à la
cantine madame martin je n'ai plus de
doute je le vois même là on l'a ou pas
on pas là je suis en bloc hors tôt dans
je suis flatté